There's little reason to fear
videogames will cause a catastrophic
labor shortage. First of all, it's a red
flag that the big gaps in hours
and employment between younger and older
men emerged during the Great Recession
and Not-So-Great Recovery. They're
plenty of potential non-gaming
explanations. For instance, during a time
of economic unrest, employers may have
demanded more education and experience
from potential employees. Moreover, if the
recession recovery played a big role in
young men working less, then work rates
should improve the further we move into the economic expansion. And guess what:
That's exactly what seems to be happening.
It's also unclear what role video games
play in long-term employment trends for
young men. Since 2000, their
employment-to-population ratio has
fallen by about 10 percentage points in
the United States. But in Japan, where
presumably they play a lot of video games,
the work ratio has actually increased
a bit over that same span. The big
problem with the U.S. economy over the
past decade isn't gaming any more than
it's automation or trade. It's the fact
that America suffered a massive
financial shock and near depression, and
it just takes a while for economies to recover.
Do you think video games keep
young men from working? let us know in
your comments. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to subscribe
for more research and videos from AEI.